Viens on fait un p'tit jeu.
Ouais, ok.
Le "ni oui ni non"
Comment tu t'appelles?
Ok... je vois où tu veux en venir
Oui.
Ah merde! Merde! J'ai perdu!
Le Blindtest
[Musique Friendzone] Feat Natoo
- Alors là... Je vois pas du tout là..
-C'est un morceau qu'on a fait à deux et t'es dedans
- Ouais ben peut-être que j'ai préféré oublier
Deviner qui je suis
Euh...
- Alors euh...
- Ouais non en fait c'est glauque.
Laisse tomber je...
- Bah c'était qui ?
-C'était Bernard Minet
- Ah j'avoue c'est glauque
Couper la radio au milieu d'une phrase et inventer la suite
[radio : le shampoing aigre doux- ]
-Euh, alors en fait...
[ Sonnerie téléphone ] (McFly & Carlito)
-Ouais bon, on change de jeu ?
- Ouais
Le jeu des...
papiers !
- Bah moi c'est ciseaux !
- Ouais le ciseau
Ouais, le ciseau il coupe la feuille hein.
- Hop là !
Le feu vert
- Moi, je dis qu'il passe au vert...
MAINTENANT !
3 , 2 , 1 ...
(BIP!!!)
0,5 ...
- Norman..
- O,1 ...
-... C'est un stop
Tu préfères
-Alors tu préfères une marque de voiture pas ouf
ou Peugeot ?
- Peugeot évidemment !
[voix robot : placement de produit effectué]
Compter les voitures
- 76 !
- Ouais... Ça c'est pas très jaune hein mais bon après...
- C'est quand même une voiture de facteur donc si c'est jaune
- Ouais jaune pastel ouais.. Ben après..
on peut tricher, hein on peut tricher si tu veux...
Cache-cache
-Heuu.. Derrière le siège ?
- Il est pas ouf ce je hein...
Les possibilités sont assez restreintes quand même
Le jeu du répète ce que je dis
-Et si on s'arrêter prendre un petit café le temps que la voiture charge?
- D'accord donc le jeu c'est de répéter ce tout ce que je dis...
- Le caca c'est délicieux !
- Oh ! Je viens de me faire larguée !
- Oh ! Je viens de me...
- Non, non non c'est pas ça que je voulais...
Allez ! on s'arrête prendre un petit café le temps que la voiture charge!
Deviner la chanson
Je sais pas !
- Bah c'est ma chanson enfait sur ma chaîne ! Natoo! (Je sais pas danser)
"Promo de la Chaine de Natoo"
- Ah donc tu fais ta promos sur ma chaîne YouTube ?
D'accord !
-Oui, Abonnez-vous !
- Ah putain mais le manque de respect !
Le Volley Ball
- Wouuuu !
Donc le schmilblick heuu...
- oui !
Le schmilblick
- C'est un animal ?
- non
- Une tortue !
- Ban non
1, 2, 3, soleil
- 1,2,3, Soleil !
1,2,...
Gagné !
-bon il est pas ouf non plus celui-là...
-non
Et toujours compter les voitures...
-Voiture jaune !
- Ah c'est bien tu vois tu remonte !
Ça fait 4 à 372 pour moi
-Et ça te dis qu'à la prochaine pause essence on arrête ce jeu?
- à la prochaine borne électrique normalement parce que c'est une voiture électrique
- Ouais donc il y a plus de batterie quand enfait ?
- Ah ben là on est large hein...
on a au moins 300 km encore
- Ah yes !
- Tu veux que je regarde où se trouve la prochaine borne d'ailleurs ?
- Non, non vas-y, continuons à s'amuser c'est exellent
- Ok.. Oh ! 373 !
[rires]
Tu vois c'est rigolo
Ah Putain...
Critiquer ses amis
C'est pas vraiment un jeu ça...
-Ah ouais ?
Moi mes parents ils faisaient ça quand il rentraient de dîner avec leur potes...
Avant de me fouetter...
Dans l'escalier... Enfin bref
Encore le ''ni oui ni non''....
- Vous voulez le menu maxi  -Effectivement
-Avec une boisson ?
- Assurément
-Les sauces vous voulez barbecue, pomme frite, curry ?
- Le second choix s'il vous plaît
- Bien joué
- Est-ce que vous prenez les tickets restaurant?
-En effet
- Vous aussi ?
- oui
- Oh ! perdu !
[rires]
- Ah j'avoue vous m'avez bien ken
Le schmilblick...
-Bon alors le schmilblick c'est un truc dont t'as besoin
- L'affection de mon père ?
[musique triste]
-non...
c'est un objet !
-Bah une lettre de mon père
qui me dirait enfin qu'il m'aime
Jouer à chat
-chat
-chat -chat -chat -chat-chat-chat
-chat -chat -chat -chat
Le schmilblick… [Encore]
[musique triste] Et là il y a eu cette pièce de théâtre quand j'avais 10 ans
où dans le public à la place de mon père j'ai vu juste un siège vide
- ouais
Bah le schmilblick c'était une fourchette
voilà
Colin Maillard
Et là je fais plusieurs tours pour bien perdre mes repères et après je dois te retrouver dans la voiture
- Ouais ben ce jeu on va pas le faire... On va faire le jeu où tu roules normal..
Chat !
-Chat -chat -chat -chat -chat -chat -chat -ouaaaaaa
Le roi du silence
- Vous avez consommé des substances illicites?
Bon ok ! Elle est bourrée, on l'embarque!
- Monsieur ! On a pas bu d'alcool, on joue juste au roi du silence là
- Perdu !
[ rires ]
- Merci mec ! - Eh gros t'as fait une tête!
c'est juste énorme
passe ton gun, passe ton gun !
après... Un retrait de permis... Tu peux vivre avec hein...
Enfin sans du coup
- Enfin, calme-toi. T'as pas le permis enfaite hein, c'est un sketch
- Pardon ?
Excuse-moi regarde : je conduis, rétroviseur, angle mort
Les mains à 10h moins le quart
- 10h 10
-Je peux faire des petits crénaux, me ranger en épis...
-Et couper !
-attendez !
- On est obliger de finir comme ça ?
-On pourrait faire croire que je sais vraiment conduire non?
tout ça pour ça
d'accord...
Bon..
Euh
Quelqu'un peut me ramener ?
Nat ?
Bon bah je crois que je vais passer le permis moi hein...
Et merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit pouce en l'air
de vous abonner, et tutti quanti
je vous aime à - la - folie !
au revoir !
Aller Voir la Chaine de Natoo